oder was geht ab hier soll wachsen
herzlich kommen zu dieser runde geht an
jan s das gilt erzählt leute wir haben
heute das folgende für euch wir spielen
eine runde sk sagt das heißt ich habe
heute in diesem video viermal die
gelegenheit max dazu zu zwingen zu
machen was ich ihm sage das heißt vier
mal darf ich ihm vorschreiben was er
machen muss zum beispiel wenn ich sage
ja max durch grad links mit dem gezänk
das darf schnee machen dann muss er
deutlicher gemacht ihre gespräche erst
mal runter hier und bring dich um dann
muss er das machen oder wenn ich ihm
sage kauft 30 kuchen und das match dann
musste sich 30 kuchen kaufen unter
keinen umständen bin ich gerade
gestorben weil ich drei kuchen im bett
mit ricotta 33 30 kuchen für 120 euro
aufgabe dabei erstmal endlos viel zeit
drauf gegangen ist wegen dem ganzen
clique nein nein also ich dass wir
hatten eben auch keine aufnahme versucht
der kalt genauso ausging
wo er effektiv etwa maxis ganzes
inventar voll war mit kuchen und erhält
zerstört wurde von dem typ mit deutlich
weniger konz aber mehr war einfach nicht
so dass wir uns nicht darüber reden ja
noch okay ansonsten würde ich sagen
spiel ex giro nummer durch
wie ist jim kerr schließlich davon
ausgehen kann dass du mit so wurde kein
changes erstellt oder war schnell ich
kann die ganze zeit schön zu stellen ich
habe vier stück insgesamt
na gut tue was du nicht schaffen kannst
aber ich bin jetzt schon die so gut
gestartet als wird wird sowieso eine
tafelrunde aber gib mir dein schönstes
tage auf sich warten sie handle sich
etwas gemeines machen oder zum einstieg
etwas nicht so gemein ist
mehr was sie zutraut was ich mir zutraue
du weißt was ich dir zu mute den typen
sonst kein call back nimmt diesen habe
ich okay du ja glück ist das nicht
gerade die sagt davor gesagt ja weiß
nicht kann die seite sondern es gesagt
man könnte immer so ein kleines päckchen
stets oben
runde das war riskant wollte man
schizophrenie runde also kran isaac mit
mir selbst war der stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp bisschen starten
ich bin ich mal gesagt bin ich irgendwie
möglich ist iris kann man das jetzt
schon zwei mit dem typen roter stand das
sind erst gesagt nein das hatte ich 20
ja okay weil auch nicht so schlimm jetzt
einspringen
das heißt es oft jetzt drei wünsche
leute natürlich kann man auch am besten
sich dinge wie in deathmatch wünschen
sie gratis shoppen gehen ist es super da
gedacht kann da kündigen ganz toll maxi
vorschreiben was er sich kaufen soll ein
flott die leute nicht gut und war simons
kita 1939 aber ich muss ja auch nicht
die meisten konzerne
ich musste mich ja immerhin einmal
umbringen und da war ich hatte ich auch
ganz viel kreuzwertheim gesicht nicht
wirklich einfach vor mein geld von
meinem gesicht hat diese karte hast dich
ja ich verstehe die leute nicht die die
boten alter wirklich ja also neue
fenster oder paletten kann ich aber
diese kann zu vermuten wenn die karte
ist dies immerhin nach sein haustier der
haustiere 2
das ist ein flüchtiger oder nein das ist
aus minecraft leben glaube ich also das
hausschwein okay es lieber etwas der
bahai religion ja ich bin ganz schön von
flotten junge du hast du so lackmann
fest die ganze arbeit durch und landete
auf übrigen blöcken weil darunter immer
noch einer ist es ist ja alles klar
rio resistenz da kommst du denn hier
kommt ja nicht mehr hin
die resistenz man nutzen so also sage
ich habe noch drei wünschen so gut wenn
hierzu mal sagen würde bringt mich um
weil halt schon arsene ist so weit unten
bist schön du bist einfach auf platz
eins
dann bleibt einfach dastehen und wartet
bis der anderen die vorbeigezogen ist
von der höhe
das ist nochmal zwei es gesagt warte bis
der anderen vorbeigezogen ist wieder
versorgt sehen glaubt verhältnisse okay
es sind in erster zweiter junger ist das
einstellen was heißt hier scheiß changes
ist wichtig was würde nur das beste
würde dieses stück trägt weiter etwas
auch riskant russland des countryman
jetzt gas gas geben vielleicht kann ich
mich jetzt wieder aufholen
da kannst du oder wartet ganz gut
gepasst ja ja ja und sie durch die
richterlich darunter foto nicole blog
nimmt dennoch mit keinem neuen 2 noch
warte jetzt mach doch mal was überlegt
wie schnell der einkaufs phase ich würde
sagen zu reisen schwert ist eigentlich
zu langweilig kauft jemand holzschwert
und enchanted das op wie möglich das ist
es sagt nummer drei ich werde das in op
holzschwert machst ansonsten darf die
rüstung die russen kaufen oder oder dass
die fans mich schon eingeplant okay okay
jetzt will ich bin richtig op enchanted
sehen
ich hab s 4 kann was drauf hauen es wird
schlechter entwirft es keine frau
freundlich wenn man dies könnte schon
klappen aber aber du weißt es am besten
ich kenne ich ja nicht so aus also
keiner sein werden nicht erst einmal
drauf klicke ich glaube es wird nicht
mehr besser ankommt seines teams drei
haus bekommst du ja schaffens 2 geht
auch oma aber deshalb lasst meine alten
mann op scherz macht das schon zu
gefehlt und ich hätte halt gerne fire is
back gehabt auf dem holzschwert aber sie
soll sich darunter auch täglich ein
bisschen das netz
ok dann zeigt er den golf verein wie die
leute einfach mal
es gibt so viele leute er verbrennt in
die runde kommen weil sie sich in der
einkaufsstraße irgendwo angesteckt
hatten ein gutes pferd wobei natürlich
generell aktiv ist ja du hast die return
ist sehr gut so alles klar aber neue
tech damage kann man sich auf jeden fall
die leute schnäbeln behalte im
hinterkopf dass ich noch einen wunsch ab
und überlebte
e2v es ist nicht so dass andere er hat
sagt fünf halbjahr aber ist dass andere
das andere das andere
du hast jetzt noch ein anderes
eisenstadt dann aber insgesamt ist das
gleich besser mit fire aspect ja ja
feier ist beides hat schon wichtig da
will ich auch wieder auf das alte zeit
gehen so verabschieden wegwarfen alter
ich wohl schon sagen hat das mal lieber
näher und das ist wichtig ja okay das
natürlich ist eine schnellere
-generation bekommen was ihr schaden
da hab ich gesagt gemerkt auge auf ok
vielleicht vielleicht da rein
du hast doch dann geht sie noch nie weiß
keiner warum sind drei mann jeder mal
hin oder schöne russell erst gut rein
gedrückt wo afag gemacht natürlich gold
apfel machen holzapfel den dennoch
bekommt jetzt ein bisschen ungelegen
muss man da ja die hühner presse schon
um den händler eigentlich schneller als
andere schwer sauber gut dass es so kalt
aber es ist ja kaum schon verdammt
haltefrist hart das war geil des mega
los jawohl die sehr schön das war's mit
weil der sr2 spieler noch weitere zwei
spieler
ich will sehen wie der andere guckt ist
ein wunsch habe ich noch ein mensch habe
ich noch die summe auf den andern drauf
was hast du noch beschwert
preise werden aber ist das was du dass
dein bester schwer ja doch ich hab noch
ein anderes relativ gutes halt das
holzschwert macht auch gut damit aber es
hat leider keine feier ist es ja das
holz schwester überlegst dir schnell ok
lauf mal kurz weg ein wunsch hast du
noch frei mein wunsch habe ich noch frei
ok der wunsch ist dass du jetzt genau
jetzt 50 und stehen bleibst 12 da hätte
ich gehen doch schlagen 345 komm schon
für alex sie war keine faxen 8 90 auf 12
13 14 54
glückspilz ist hier nicht hinterher
gelaufen der dich wegklatschen können
man aber wie den todes komplette der
bleibt im land an land stehen warum
nicht hat er angst hätte dass ich das
web als ob solch ein check du dir zahlen
alle sehr saftig aus gibt es solche gibt
es skepsis manager muss also dass du im
wasser falls peters ja die hitze schon
ein bisschen komisch aus ja ich will was
sieht sieht sie komisch aus aber wir
schauen mal drauf was ist ein wirkliches
bekommen ermitteln wir haben ja den den
begründer der hacker schau dir ein
professionelles auge kommt einfach ich
hab' ich lass mich ruhig regenerieren
die kombi zip-datei weile dauern bis ich
den kaffee ein bisschen schlucken of
doing sagt bisher schon bestanden ich
muss ich melde dich
gut hielt mir damit jetzt in diesem
moment für für es gesagt spieler weiter
erhöhen können dann dann kommt
wahrscheinlich meldet er dich weil wir
nicht angreifen kann er halt hat mega
komisch ja der es oft ärger der hat mega
komische media.com haider hätte mich
doch respekt gestorben also das war
schon ein bisschen nach auto kicker aus
leute also die leute wie mega komisch
dass da gar nicht nicht normal so wie
heute auch nur gequält obwohl eigentlich
werden eltern nicht gesprungen
ganz konkret ex autoclick aber man weiß
es nicht paar expert unter euch gibt es
bestimmte können reinschreiben was ihr
denkt an gelassen was das so weit von
uns bis zur nächsten folge von ein café
mit